I'm a self-taught filmmaker I never went  to film school I never studied film  monkey in any way I started making films  uh when I was a kid when I was I think  seven years old uh making films using my  dad's Super 8 camera and the action  figures doing stop motion films a little  bit of animation and a certain amount of  live action and I just carried on making  films as I grew up over the years they  got  bigger hopefully better but but more  elaborate and there never really was a  period in my life where I completely  stopped doing it so I was always moving  up eventually from Super 8 to 16  millimeter films and then I felt very  young and very inexperienced and I felt  that  my own life and the things I saw and the  world were not going to be of interest  to people  but they felt interesting to me and so I  was looking for a language I was looking  for a genre in which I could take  things that I was interested in  and make them accessible make them  interesting to other people